is the hijab 10
discount code for 10 percent discount on
a wide range of products including
premium ethiopian black seed products
[Music]
[Laughter]
and
joining me is the man that's like
saliva please
please
the the daoa machine
the marriage documentary
we haven't done this kind of
collaboration for some time yeah yeah
i've tried to you know this is myself
from you know because the personal
assailant said you know bad friends are
like you know blacksmith you know so
no joking yeah yeah man it's been a long
time we've been chilling out man i think
it's been more relaxed well like
sometimes you get fed up of just filming
filming so we just chilled out but you
know sometimes when important topics
come
and when it pertains to
um the family unit which is already
under attack
i think it's important for us to you
know
jump
head first you know because the
important topic and this is something
that in the next couple of months we're
going to be going straight into as well
um because you know we've got the whole
lgbqt uh we've got gender roles that
we're going to be talking about as well
inshallah so i think it's a serious
topic and i think we've had enough break
chilling out and i think it's time to
get back to business
um yeah so this is what we wanted to
comment on today inshallah is this a
youtube channel which i've been made
aware of called honest tea talks and
actually we welcome it a lot of brothers
we you know we've spoken to
um in different parts of the world
are very much against this kind of thing
where women come out and they and they
bring their own perspective and they
speak on behalf of other women that have
maybe they've been in communication with
you know they come out and they attack
they're very triggered just like the
idea of women coming and speaking on a
public platform yeah from from our kind
of
interactions with people in in the west
et cetera
um all the different countries have been
to a different universities don't you
think it's in the muslim how the common
interest
of the muslim community to have women
actually speak
independently uh in the way that these
women are doing of course man it's
important you know these very people who
come in this whole notion of you know
they shouldn't be there they shouldn't
talk etc you know and then it's the same
people where they're when they're due to
our force in the shadow they might not
listen to us maybe they want to listen
to a sister if they go through other
dilemmas in life what they go through
maybe they want to listen to a co-sister
because they can relate to do you get it
and most of the times if you see i've
incorporated when i'm doing a reaction
video or certain topics pertaining to
sisters i get a sister on board because
i don't know what they go through so
it's important for us to incorporate
this but people who are living in a box
don't realize that when their kids go
through this and you limit them to a
certain point some of them end up
leaving the deen because of this
attitude you know so we appreciate and
value
sisters like themselves you know
honestly talk it's good
but also we need to also keep each other
in check you know it's the same goes
with me to you you to me
to you
yeah no we have to because if we don't
keep
each other in check you know then we're
going to go straight like you know the
the people in the past have gone astray
it's important and this is what this
deen upholds in joining good and
forbidden evil it's fundamental only
above the exact men and the believing
women yes both of them are allies to one
another exactly before we get to some
points of correction that we want to
kind of address in this video and and
constructive criticism quite frankly on
on
some of the content that we've we've
witnessed
we want to say that actually
one of the most controversial videos
that they've made in terms of
public controversy it's been one that
basically they were coming out and
talking about women's sexual rights like
intimate rights and stuff it got a lot
of views a lot of people were very upset
at the fact that women were saying like
you know there's an issue in the
community where men are not
sexually pleasing uh women basically
like they have a laissez-faire attitude
or
you know a non-existent
drive when it comes to women sexuality
and stuff like that i personally didn't
find that much controversy in that
message at all yeah do you see this
problem i mean if we have a problem with
that then we shall have a problem with
the answer woman who came to the process
you know and and aisha and i said you
know may i'll have mercy on them and
said a woman you know when it comes to
these matters they're up front you know
and obviously there's an
adab about how you address it and i
don't believe they
cross those limits from what i remember
maybe they might have been one occasion
something was said i can't remember but
other than that other than that bro who
are we to talk about modesty brother
you know and also for those that have an
issue like brothers like why are you
even watching that yeah yeah i mean to
be fair didn't even go into x-rated
stuff they didn't go into i mean there's
more to be said by way by way of
discussion and things that men should
give women sexually and women vice versa
like you can actually you can go more
into detail but we won't be doing that
today maybe that's another video for
another day what we will be doing today
insha'allah though is we're looking at
some of the things that have been
happening in this or some things that
have been said and let me be
straightforward and say
there are some things which are missing
in the content and i'll tell you what i
think the number one thing which is
missing in this kind of content is
is reference to the religion direct
reference like okay so for example
you know i've watched a few of the
episodes now right
divorce is one of them divorce is a very
complicated topic
very complicated and a very dangerous
it's a live wire
and i personally believe that if you
want if we wanted to speak about divorce
we'd have to do extensive shoulder with
people like scholars and stuff like that
and vet it and stuff like that because
if you give wrong advice when it comes
to divorce it can literally ruin
lives it's dangerous but i'll be honest
with you i don't think there would be a
point where we could ever talk about
divorce look when i go to shaykh and
people of knowledge like that bro when
we go to him and ask about you know
there's this prophet going through this
the first thing says to me is bring that
brother to me exactly and he'll bring
his wife to me he's not going to come
and say ali go tell the brother
or something has happened that's just
created a massive wedge they've tried
they've done all that they can to
improve their marriage it's just not
happening
and yet they have a
level of care
and love maybe not in love but a level
of care and love for each other
is divorced the right option in that
case
it's a personal choice but it sounds
like yes like it
it can't you know if that's a rare model
i think a lot of times when you see a
marriage coming to the point where
people are thinking about divorce it's a
hostile environment and it's it's not
it's not usually amicable and
everybody's i'm sure they've processed
their i see different so many of the
cases that i know
i see people maybe you're looking at it
from the loveless marriage perspective
like they've grown to this point but
when i see divorce coming up it's
usually in a hostile
setting it's it's in a chaotic hostile
setting like things have erupted and now
divorce looks like let's just end this i
see i see both i see both i'm
encountering both yeah i'm encountering
um sisters who are just empty
their husbands are good men
um but they're just empty and they crave
connection
um
and they just say they're really just
running on empty i don't know how long
they can continue like this for so it's
for them i think sometimes that's a a
deeper predicament because he's not
abusing me
you know he's actually good to me
um
but it's i'm potentially choosing by
saying i'm potentially choosing
a completely loveless and sometimes even
sexless
marriage
yes
so can you see here when when he asked
the somali sister sorry i don't know her
name yeah
when he asked the somali sister she said
it's a personal choice but yes yeah
now for me that's too nonchalant yeah
and it's quite frankly it's damaging
it's dangerous too ambiguous as well
what do you mean by like um like divorce
in what
because you need to understand something
yeah these issues are deep issues and
it's it's and these issues get a lot of
views because a lot of people are going
through it yeah it's not islam q a
saying for example somebody mentions i'm
going through this
yeah okay in this situation
he says maybe it might be best to
divorce i doubt they would ever say that
and then you have a wonder general mass
and writing i'm having a problem shall i
divorce and that comes up and they're
like
yeah and then and then they apply it to
their self that's dangerous that fatwa
is specific to a specific individual
like i think it was
somebody came to him and said
if i kill someone would i be forgiven
and he said you'll never be forgiven
and then another person came same
question he said will that be forgiven
he said you'll be forgiven
people around you what you're saying is
that for for
for each individual yes because the
reason is they asked him they said why
did you say to one he won't be forgiven
and to the other you would he said the
first one i saw he is about to kill
and the second one had already killed
he's looking for mercy so do you see how
they differentiated between giving their
ruling to two separate individuals well
the famous examples were the prophet
were about kissing the
older man
and the younger man he allowed it the
point of the matter is it's the divorce
should not be spoken is it okay to
divorce it's not okay first of all we
have to appreciate something there's
different models of divorce yes like a
woman what can she do is different to
what a man can do yes i know that it's
such a very straightforward thing to say
but that's not fleshed out in this video
what a woman can do is hola she can do
faceha okay she can ask the man for hola
yeah so the man gives it he grants it to
her and what hola is different to talaq
according to some some is actually the
same all of these are very important
details in it how does hola
differentiate from a talaq if it is in
fact the opinion you follow or what what
has to happen et cetera
the point is if if you if you give women
or
people the ammunition to just go
actually women in this case yeah to
their husbands and say i want a divorce
because i'm not i'm not in love with you
no more you could actually be pushing
them to do a major sin because that
might not be
that might not be a valid reasoning now
there's a difference between repugnance
or
because when when the woman came to the
prophet muhammed
in bukhari
between them this is repugnance this is
not it's not the same as not having the
love that they're talking about whatever
that may mean by the way and that's
that's a sliding scale so if someone is
is put like disgusted by their husband
okay
that's com that's a different kind of
fish to someone who is
falling out of love with the same
passion what about if the man is not
having intimacy with you now that's
that's a good point because she
mentioned that at the end because i
believe she conflates yeah
yeah no no the first question was
different to the second because
the second part of what she said was it
could be a second sexless marriage but
that sexless marriage could be coming
from the woman because she don't have
sex with a man or i'm assuming that's
what she means but if she means that the
man is not giving herself
that's a separate issue of inquiry but
even then bro do you not think they're
complaining
they're confusing two things there which
is dangerous because first she said what
um
look look this is very important bro
yeah he's a good guy
yeah there's an abuser kids his kids
one second one second that sounds like a
good guy to me yeah but and she's keep
talking about a woman being empty empty
on what what are you trying because what
do you mean by that i'm asking the
sister because then you added no sex
let's take the no 6 out of the picture
because there might be a person
there might be a young sister watching
this video yeah and be like
no he does have intimacy with me he's
actually a good guy he's everything you
just said but i don't feel i'm not
feeling empty yeah you've just given
them an advice of divorce yeah you've
basically said you're empty you
shouldn't be feeling empty how do you
define this empty no no they need to be
careful with this they're very dangerous
and this is something like would you
respect if that's what they're saying
publicly i'm worried to know what they
would be saying privately if if people
are coming to that because you have no
right let me just make this very clear
you have no right to advise any woman of
divorce unless you've heard two sides of
the story and you are qualified to be
able to make such a judgment i don't
have a right and you don't have a right
to do that if if the case is simple and
straightforward
yeah where the man is you know he's
putting her through this and that and
her life is on the line that's different
we're not talking about this yes we're
talking about very ambiguous cases right
now you have no right to advise any
woman at any point yeah when you have
not heard two sides of this that's why
in khabar yeah it might have to do with
judgment yeah yeah they'll bring both if
they know what they're doing yeah
they'll bring both parties in and
they'll hear both sides yes
they have to do that you have to and
they have to know what they see the kids
what the situation with the kids because
you could be breaking homes you think
you're making things better but you're
not you're making things worse you are
making things worse and and then that
will be on your skills on the day of
judgement exactly you know we need to be
very careful i want to be careful
hate them
says look sometimes sisters come and
they're crying we're human beings when
we see individuals crying we sympathize
that's right but until we go sometimes
i'm not just saying this only happens
with sister's side sometimes it's the
man but he goes once we come and speak
to the husband
it's a whole dif like it's like yes it's
slightly different it's that green color
and it's like totally the total opposite
that's right and they're like oh come on
i want to move on to the next video
because there's more things going sorry
that's there's more there's more issues
here with with some of the content
but what the content is missing as i say
is quran
like you you can go through the whole
video yeah and once again we're
constructively criticizing and no would
you respect no chivalry effect is going
to stop us from doing it because you
deserve the peer review
that we all get yeah and this is peer
review you've got to think of it like
that and it's if these peer review
systems didn't were not in place the
muslim ummah would be
uh
would have a bad service
at the end of the day yeah of course we
do too
by everyone public and private yeah
exactly so this is just consider this
constructive critic we're not saying and
just to be clear again that therefore
let's cancel them therefore they don't
know what they're talking about
therefore the ignorant we're saying that
you're doing a good job masha allah but
just on these points please bear in mind
that you need to change some of the
parlance here's what i would say the
first let's summarize each thing as we
go along here first thing when it comes
to divorce when it comes to issues with
khabar or judgement
keep out of it
keep out of it unless and only unless
you have someone who is extremely well
qualified
a woman let's say if you want to keep it
all woman that's fine but she's
extremely she's she's a well-known uh
taliba
or sheikha or something you bring her
and she speaks with the authority that
she has but if you just lay people
speaking about divorce and issues that
can break families this will do more
than good second thing here is this i
was watching uh think gender roles in
the community yeah yeah now i watched
this particular video for another
purpose
obviously our email is a dollar remit we
have a completely different room for
them
is more pastoral so they're dealing with
women's issues and these kind of things
but there is a significant intersection
right
so there are things which we do and they
do which intersect
and and this is one of them so she this
is one of the things that she said
gender roles in the community so we're
talking about generals between men and
women i can't let obviously you can't
watch the whole thing i can't watch the
whole thing
but let me tell you one thing that was
not mentioned in the entire video the
entire video
however was not mentioned
was not mentioned which is the male
responsibility or
the ability for him to have uh
one degree yeah that he's a maintainer
of the protector
the hierarchical hierarchical uh
uh superiority that a man has over a
husband have a wife that's not mentioned
that's that is the elephant in the room
that's what makes
a traditionalist complementarian system
of marriage different from an
egalitarian system so if you're going to
do a video of gender roles you have to
define what the gender roles are in the
first place
yeah we haven't even defined what gender
roles are and worse yet worse yet quite
frankly
you start to mix liberal ideas with
islamic ideas let's let's listen to what
we're talking about here
and if you think about it subhanallah
when you look at different couples
allah pairs someone with what they need
with who they need so you have a strong
powerful woman who's active who's maybe
running a business who has a career the
man is more mellow
when you have a man that is out there
yeah he's in the tower he's you know
he's working he's busy busy busy you've
got a woman who is holding down the
floor
listen listen listen
i mean that was your second name quite
quite
anyways let's get to the point let's see
they're using my name
the strong powerful woman
once again you have to look at the
language yeah the strong powerful woman
that's running her own business
all these kinds of things that she's
doing strong why is strong and powerful
correlated with capitalistic success
yeah exactly in this whole video
seldomly do they do they mention exactly
what the traditional roles are
there is no clear definition of it
and in fact i don't think they've ever
mentioned and someone can correct me if
i'm wrong
uh concepts of tar concepts of kawama
they've cleanly mentioned it clearly
delineated it what is it it's the
equivalent of men not telling men other
men what their responsibilities are in
islam if you want to help women in the
community you need to tell them what
their responsibilities are
actually telling them only what their
rights are yeah what
will arm them to make their homes
more hostile places because they're now
stocked up with all these things about
okay what we need to get what what
what's best for me i have to be i have
to be a career woman i have to do this i
have to do that where are these coming
from yeah no one's saying muslim woman
can't work but the terminologies you're
using are very similar to what the
liberals talk about day in and day out
what we're saying is that these are
dangerous because we know the study done
over 20 years
over a hundred thousand women
are women more happier hmm no they're
not there
talking about blanche flower in oswald
you know the the hundred thousand people
how long did this study for 20 years
yeah 20 years 100 000 women we're not
talking a hundred a thousand one hundred
thousand women and women are less and
less happier yeah and we'll put the link
to the on the description let's happy
after the after second world sorry after
the second uh wave of feminism after all
the implementations of the the point is
is that we need to be clear that there
is in fact there are gender roles in
islam and those gender roles do mean
that the men uh ideally will be i'm not
saying always what is wrong with that
breadwinners
what is wrong with the how what because
whatever define it let's say no bro the
studies show it jordan peterson has one
of the reasons he's blown up is because
he states this fact he talks about for
example when
women who are working in the you know in
these
whatever um sectors it might be that
they when it comes to their 30s 40s
they're leaving their jobs
they're leaving their jobs because
they're realizing that they're putting
in 60 70 hours work
and and they're looking at their life
and there's nothing to account for you
are preparing yourself to a lonely death
you've reached the age of 30 to 40
you're a career woman who's got a lot of
money in their bank and you've got no
man that wants to marry you
and you and and let's talk about
biologically can you have children no so
the thing is why are we propagating a
failed system where studies show that
women are less happier that's true it's
true it's dangerous and i'm not saying
that there's fully probably getting
there but you've got to be clear about
what the islamic ideal is yeah because
if you're going to do a whole video
about gender roles and not mention one
quranic verse one hadith or one color
any islam and then at the end of it
refer to women that start their own
business and do well in the workplace or
are public figures whatever it may be as
strong
the an implication that could be taken
from that is or the influence that can
be taken from that at least in the
subtext of that speech is that strong
women are those women that the liberals
are defining not or the liberal feminist
side of finding exactly you know
basically put it this way put it this
way if you watch that whole gender video
that they made it's not incompatible
with feminism
it's not yet it's not incompatible with
feminism i don't think like
a second way feminist will look at it
and probably not disagree with most of
what is being said yeah if if they're
liberal enough to different cultures
they won't disagree with also
in order for us to really know once
again if we want islamic solutions for
muslim problems we have to bring the
quran
simple as that really if you're if you
want to give islamic solutions for
muslim problems bring the quran and the
sunnah tell them of the ayat and the
hadith and the quran otherwise it's to
be honest with you it's uh it will be
just opinion forget this a super
powerful career well forget that okay
yeah yeah why don't we why don't our
sisters are doing this honestly talk
yeah and it's honestly they're being
honest about it here they should be
grilling brothers and saying you sisters
you go to your husbands you're the
maintainer and the protector of the
house go out and work empower them by
them they might be doing that no no no
they should not i've seen i haven't seen
a video of them
incorporating that bro they should
incorporate that and talk to sisters and
tell them you tell your husband you're
the maintainer protector i accept that
and this is what allah legislated go out
and work you might find segments of them
saying that remember
i hope yeah yeah let's let's see this
bit here
this is
you're talking about dying alone and
living is that we do understand like
kevin bloody samuels nobody's true but
this is one thing that i was i was
watching how to find a husband yeah yeah
so listen to this bit i found it quite
unusual to be honest this is quite
unusual really
uh
build upon their confidence and to know
exactly what they will and won't accept
and to journey
through the uh um
the looking stage with allah knowing
that allah will give them
what they need and what they deserve
when you know divorced women are not
second-class citizens just because they
were divorced i mean if you look at the
time
of the prophet saw islam how many of us
have yet to divorcees widows
and and the sahaba rush to marry them
subhanallah so even the prophet
and the prophet himself yes so it's so
so important that i think for for
divorce sisters
that they
that they come to
the brother who's already married who's
looking for a second wife why is it the
assumption
that because you're divorced that you
that you that necessarily your
preference is polygamy i mean it may be
for some women it may not be but it's
almost as though i see
and you know i don't know if you see
this too that for divorce sisters
there's a narrative that's kind of
shoved down their throats that okay
because you're divorced you need to
lower your standards
you need to accept
anyone that's going to take you because
you have kids because who's going to
marry a sister with fortune and you
should be grateful that anyone wants to
marry you right and and i
am totally against this
i am totally against this i think it's
really really important never mind there
so
polygyny is an institution in islam they
know it they've done a video on it yeah
which was a biased video which which
itself requires discussion but we don't
have time for it today yeah but
basically that video they've done and it
was just prioritizing
uh the trauma of the first wife not
putting the second wife in the equation
at all almost her trauma or the or the
the kids
maybe the kids are there or even the
yani it was it was a biased video and in
fact they should they should title that
video the dysfunctionalities of
polygeny and implementation not polygamy
as they have yeah but put that to the
side
this video here that they've done
which uh sorry this this mukta here this
little bit
this little video bit here where she was
saying that someone who's divorced
should not should not accept the fact
that you know and it's true we don't say
that she should lower her standards or
think that she's less i agree yeah no
problem but listen to what she says
thereafter yeah okay so she says that i
i agree with what she said so far so do
i but this is what i found quite ironic
[Music]
of the prophet saws
how many of us have yet to divorcees
widows
and and the sahaba rush to marry them
subhanallah so
yeah but you see what do you think i'm
going to say here so she she said in the
first instance
that you shouldn't if there's a woman
who's a divorcee she shouldn't just
accept poligning right
and then she mentioned that the example
of habit and the prophet's wives
what do you think the disparity here is
in these two examples
you tell me you said it before uh okay
the disparity in these two examples is
those women who are divorcees married in
politicians marriages
so there were divorce women who got into
polygamy that's what i'm saying
if you mention in the prophet muhammad
as an example he had nine wives at one
time
yeah so these women were divorcees yes
but they were also getting the religious
marriages okay but but there are
companions who didn't marry divorced
women without being in polygamy
very very unlikely to be honest they
might have had the
air and they might have had the milky
mean and stuff that that was like that
was the exception
let's talk about the sabbath mentality
are you telling me none of the sahabas
would have wanted to marry
like for example that sahabah who came
actually oh no no the one the process of
said why did you not marry a virgin he
said i married a divorce you asked kids
because yeah but yeah we don't know
that's the only wife he's gone no
and we don't know if he we also don't
know that he didn't know at that time
but what i'm trying to say is the
possession of the right hand and stuff
okay no problem but let's let's be real
didn't have the mentality of i will not
marry a divorcee because she's a
divorcee no that would not we agree with
okay but that's what they're trying to
no i understand it but what i'm saying
is it's not it's not lowering your
standard necessarily i agree if if for
divorcee now she's got four kids or the
example they gave or five or six or
whatever it may be yeah
for her to realize that that is yeah
okay that is going to be an
inconvenience for a lot of men that is
going to be an inconvenience so what are
you saying what i'm saying is that's the
reality
that's how it should be thank you but
once again
we should make another thing clear which
is that he has no responsibility over
them the father and she does have
responsibility he has no respect he
doesn't need to give the money work yeah
anything so the point of the matter is
he cannot have his goodwill but he's
responsible if
with the advice has been given yeah is
not going to help yes let's just be
honest about it polygyny is there for a
reason it is there to make sure that
women who are
married or unmarried who may be
divorcees and cannot find husbands and
have been looking for five years 10
years whatever it may be
yeah can be absorbed back into the
marriage market yeah if they take this
kind of advice they sorry to say
the reality is yeah
they may die alone
it's not productive i think what the
issue here is this year look when i was
looking to get married yeah there was a
sister i was getting to know for
marriage who had kids
yeah and i wasn't thinking about
polygamy yeah yeah i was like my your
liar
i wasn't thinking about polygamy in my
head i was like if this is the right
person to me i accepted myself okay
maximum i would i would i could marry a
divorce with two kids that was maximum
three i personally
wouldn't personally the point i'm trying
to make here why are they equating and a
woman can have such a preference as well
she can say okay i don't want to marry a
man with kids thank you thank you
the point is this why is it yeah seen as
degrading that a divorced sister
gets into a polygamy
i don't understand this because it's to
be fair they don't say that no no it
does come across i'm totally against
that um
unless she's talking about that they are
seen as second-class citizens i doubt
they are because if a man is willing to
marry you he's not making you a side
chick yeah exactly
we need to marry you and you're a
divorcee okay no problem he's not saying
oh i'm going to marry you maybe for the
sake of allah maybe he can marry someone
younger but he's like look i want to
marry a sister with kids maybe because
the society that we live in sadly see
them as low value women like these red
people wherever they talk as and because
of that i want to marry them what is
wrong with that why do you feel degraded
why is this notion of look you go to the
moment you say something you gotta
admire about them
what did they call each other not called
wife that's my cool sister
yeah okay they say cool sister which
muslim sister would come today and say
that's my co-sister
go to sub-saharan africa do you know you
know we're talking in the western
context but you know do you know where
there are some places in the world where
the culture of polygamy is much it's
much more acceptable and women are much
more agreeable to it for example
people correct me if i'm wrong yeah but
sub-saharan africa nigeria forgot
nigeria go to indonesia apparently in
indonesian malaysia we've been told
anyway yes that is people are much more
open to yeah you know what i'm talking
about
but here's a segment okay so we've
talked about that so it's just to
summarize just to summarize this point
the the idea really is about
you know you know pollution is there for
a reason yeah of course it helps with
the marriage market
i don't want and everyone get don't get
advice that's unproductive okay one
second yeah well life polygamy is a
solution yes i don't care what i'll take
off my life they said to me we will hang
you and say
where do you want to hug me
myself
the point is this yeah
is a solution because what you need to
understand is polygamy is not exclusive
to muslim men
men practice polygamy in the wrong ways
allah has stipulated to be done in the
right way so co-wives be you a divorce
or no divorcee with kids or no kids you
have your rights protected okay so it's
been legislated so things can be done in
the right way i know many sisters would
message me when i when i first came to
islam and i started my youtube channel i
was doing a reality show yeah bro trust
me i used to get messages from sisters
who were on the verge of falling into
zinna because they are looked down upon
they are single mothers who have kids
nobody want to marry them they go into
these apps on all these men one like
they'll say to me i go into this app
once they find that i'm a divorcee with
kids they start flirting with me they
start talking to me in a certain way
when a man comes and he wants to marry
you why are you degrading that man why
are you making it unacceptable please
the point is this here yeah
once again i want to emphasize your
videos are good well light is needed all
we're just trying to say is there's
certain things that you're seeing that
have great consequences because don't
think it's the words that you utter
there are people that are watching and
thinking actually right or this stuff
actually let me divorce actually they're
making life-changing decisions you know
so what we're just trying to say sisters
is when you say something look because
you said you watched a lot all the
videos and they don't know
yeah but like five or six okay well then
to me it might be that you're talking
from experience yeah and i'm not talking
about the specific issue of divorce i'm
not talking about that so you need to
some of them are divorces they make it
clear okay but what i'm saying is that
if you bring your experiences to the
table it's not necessarily wrong but
what you may have gone through or what
you have suffered
what you are still suffering that you
may not have not been over
can cause harm because what you're doing
is you
i'm not pointing to any of these sisters
what i'm saying is it might be something
we all have gone through stuff in our
life if i come and give a deci
if somebody comes asking for advice and
i say oh do this because i'm in a mental
state of something that i've suffered my
advice might not be productive this is
what this is called it's called
self-referential altruism interesting
and the only you'll find these kind of
words apply
self-referendum
self-referential altruism is where
there's
self-referential altruism basically
altruism is when you care about other
people right self-referential altruism
is you care about other people or you
give advice that would let's say for
example impact other people because you
refer to your own experiences now this
is actually a very poor way to moralize
because it's first of all it's very um
it's a very small sample size you've got
yourself just
and that person like you said subjective
experience yeah that that person might
go go for a completely different yeah
with this analogous set of things and
what you're doing is you're projecting
your kind of own emotional yes energy
onto them it's it's like it's a form of
freudian projection but let's put that
to the side yeah let's see this next bit
because this advice gets worse to be
honest that is because to feel to be
accepted to be wanted they feel like if
i
show that i'm a mother then that means
i'm not good i'm going to be less
desirable
you know
it's so important this is who i am this
is how i am and this is what i've got
and
are you down
and if if listen ladies
if okay the man
asks you listen for the red flags red
flags yeah can they live with their
father
he's not accepted your kids are they
going to be living in us full time
he's not accepted your kids listen out
for these
living with the father is actually the
it's actually the ruling
if a woman is divorced
and she remarries the majority of
islam from
my understand based on the hadith in
timothy by the way with them whether
where the prophet muhammad saw a
movement came to him says shall i get
how could i not get custody of the
children when she was they were on my
you know lap and they were suckling from
my breasts and whatever and he said you
get custody of the children but if you
get married
then he gets the children that's the
ruling so if you get custody of the
children
obviously doesn't mean that the man
doesn't see them yeah
it just means that you get you're the
primary like custodian of the guardian
of the child now but if you get married
then he the father now gets custody of
the children so if if a man comes how
could that be a red flag if he just
wants to do ikama of the hadood of allah
okay or the
the
he wants he wants to uphold i think
i think she's talking about something
else no i don't think so it's not it's
not reflection
no no she's not she she said listen to
the red flags yeah
she said if he says can they go and live
with their father then he hasn't
accepted your children now if he says
that he can go and live with your father
that might just be because
that that's where they need to go okay
can it be also that for example
the father doesn't want them and the guy
that she's getting to know is basically
saying i don't want them in my life kind
of like i don't want them there i think
that's where she's coming from even if i
don't think she's coming that's what he
says it's the right of that fight you
get it otherwise how can you say that
assuming the best for the sake of uh for
the sake of argument but this is either
way it's not red flag if the man doesn't
if a man says look i really don't want
to get involved with with children i've
got my own children
to raise i don't see anything wrong with
that likewise if not i don't see
anything
no no if a woman wants to get if a woman
wants to get married to a man who's got
children yeah she says look i don't want
to i don't want to raise your children
what did you do i don't see anything
wrong with that how does that work what
did you do with the kids what do you
mean what does what does she do with the
kids can you imagine you're speaking to
a man and the man said how old are the
kids how old are they let's say they're
eight and nine
depends on the situation no one he
doesn't want to raise them but he
doesn't because
he's his catch 22 for a lot of men yeah
you want to raise a child yeah but then
when you get into their life yeah you're
number two because you are not the final
decision maker you will not be given the
same privileges as you would be if
you are the father and this goes on
listen to what they continue saying yeah
listen to what the somali system says
yeah okay you'll see more you get a
flavor of what they're talking about
right
because that is a sign of whether he is
ready to assume them into his fold or
not and or absolute indifference
you can state that they're there up
front but sometimes you get the case
where they're acting like they don't
exist there's no interest whatsoever
about their names their ages their it's
like they're not in their the way they
project the future they're not taking
them into account like you said and also
in the position of the mom
your your current home you know your
home environment has a particular
balance right now it's stable it's set
it has a culture and you're going to
bring an outsider into that culture and
you have to take into account whether
they're going to be a good fit for the
culture or not somebody who's going to
come in and be uptight and throw off
your balance and shush your kids and
change your home dynamic
and that can be applied to
so think of it this way early yeah so
the guy he wants
he this is this is the conundrum that
you're putting the man in yeah
he either comes in he comes in and
assumes the children he says you know i
have no problem raising the kids
he raises the kids but part of raising
children is disciplining them you start
shushing the kids now that's nonsense
that that what she said there about you
can't say shush is nonsense other than
that
that's the dynamic that other than that
this is the problem people are facing no
no no but that's nonsense about what
she's saying about a a person coming in
it's it's you need to understand it's
their children but a man who doesn't
even actually doesn't know their name
doesn't care about them that is
concerning to anyone even if i'm a
father and have a child and the woman
says the same thing but it no i have to
be real because come on but if you're
not even acknowledging my kids and you
want them out there is red flags to me
bro i have to be real if your sister is
coming and saying how many kids do i
have two kids from another marriage how
many days you keep them three days uh oh
brother that's a red flag bounce because
you're disregarding my kids you can come
and say look for example we can work
extension
if a new wife comes and you've got kids
from nevada and you start saying like
now you've got a raise you've got raised
my children as if it's no no no no no no
that's that's that's what happens
no no no many women do this men and
women both do this you've got kids from
another marriage yes they've got another
father or they got another mother let's
say yeah
why are they not taking why are you not
assuming the responsibility of the
parent now why are you now putting that
responsibility on someone else it's very
simple i don't think anyone can force
anyone to come and say look after my
kids the person that you marry if they
do the good will they do it but when
they come in come and tell them you have
to if they come in yeah and and and you
they want to assume that responsibility
whatever yeah yeah and they start you
know
discipline the child
what you're gonna say i'm sorry that's
just my child i'm sorry that that is
that's that's nonsense without your
respect to the sister to say you can't
what is what's this what the hell is
this i've married you i've accepted your
kids and i can't discipline that what
they're talking about i i'll be honest
this is pathetic yeah what is this
this is my sleeve in the house yeah
exactly you've made him basically
so you've got your own dynamics so this
goes back to kawamaya which they don't
mention ever yeah in the videos that
i've seen
that
you basically want the hawama because if
he's in the house and he he can't shush
the kids
what's what's happened to him he's
become an equal of one of the kids so if
you shush the kids what you're going to
discipline him what are you going to do
are you going to undermine him in front
of the kids
and let's see how long such a marriage
lasts
your marriage ain't gonna last my friend
yeah honestly because if you want to
undermine the disrespect a man in front
of your children even though he wants to
come in and contribute to their
upbringing and upkeep or or their
discipline and then what you're doing is
you're basically you're self-sabotaging
you are things that's what i was going
to say because at the end of the day
you're just proning yourself to being
divorced regularly yes and i'm sorry if
that sounds harsh because if you have a
man who's coming to willing to look
after your kids loving etc and you're
coming in boston you can't say shush to
my kids don't you ever raise it look you
can be protective but you've married
this person if you trust this person you
fall into your house to your life yeah
if he wants to discipline the kids i'm
not talking about you come home and he's
flipping the talking
so these are just some of the things
that we've come across it is a vast
topic there is a version it is a notion
there's a lot of things you can talk
about
the points let's let's just let's
summarize and give constructive
criticism yeah
to summarize look number one don't get
involved with issues that have any
implication of what is referred to as
prada which means islamic rulings
because these kind of things they
require
an arbitrator they require someone to
come in and to see
person one person two side person one
side and to make a decision holistically
especially when it comes to divorce
divorce
and i'm really sorry to say this
for people that want or considering it
man or woman do not approach lay people
like us like them yes don't approach us
for uh for i'm i'm thinking of divorce
yeah yeah i'm thinking of a hola
number two yeah number two the second
thing i say is you have to start if you
if you want islamic solutions for muslim
people and you've got a demographic
which is uniquely let's say female right
then you have to start introducing the
quran more regularly yeah yeah yeah and
you have to emphasize and don't shy away
from emphasizing the key components of
the religion especially with intergender
dynamics and stuff so for example kawama
the kind of emphasis that is put by the
prophet muhammad these concepts would
would to us indicate that that should be
that kind of emphasis should be put by a
man or woman who wants to speak about
these issues to muslim people yeah and
especially on pastoral levels number
three what uh so we said number one
number two
uh
number three
i would say this bro i would actually
say it would benefit you guys if you had
one person of knowledge yes a female
yeah yes it doesn't have to be about at
all you get a female
to look over your stuff and not only
that but to sit with you guys so you can
actually consult her so you can get it's
because these are pastoral issues
in many ways they're actually even more
complicated than thou issues yeah
they're more complicated so you need a
thick specialist on hand
and because some of the blunders that
are coming out would suggest that you
don't have that kind of thing and if you
have someone there with you they can do
is tiddle they can do shad meaning you
they would be bringing out quran ayah
sunnah hadith and that's what the that's
what this thing is missing apart from
that you guys are doing good work of
course and hopefully you didn't take
offense to this we need to check each
other and hold each other account some
of the advice that was given has to be
productive
and it also has to be realistic can it
and we hope we because we have the same
objective we're on the same team we are
on the same team yeah and the objective
is to get people in stable families you
know and people can get people away from
zina so my question to you is that when
is your marriage fraudulent documentary
coming out
i mean
let me tell you something it's not
coming out is it it is coming out and
when it is come out when it does come
out
it would be groundbreaking yeah box
office smashing yeah it's gonna cause
earthquakes in the um i'm speculating
maybe here 10.7 on the with this game
yeah it's going to cause and the reason
why because this is about it goes up to
9. no no this has gone above that
brother yeah this is called tsunamis in
the regions yes people drowned you know
people drown people need life jackets
the point the point is but it is i'll be
honest it is a big topic man and it's
and that is what i aim to do when i
release it it's to delve
down
yes usual
delve into the topic because it is such
a big ocean yeah and there's so many
problems actually and the reason why i
was a bit passionate and aggressive in
the video i want to give a disclaimer
it's not towards the sisters it's
because it's satisfying misogynist
you know what's really sad to see bro is
because i hear left right center hello
yeah but i'm getting a divorce i'm
getting a divorce i'm going to say bro
it's a pandemic yeah so the thing is
this when we have that issue
of the ummah bro it's dangerous we want
to
we don't want people to get divorced
okay because divorce
marriages mean broken families broken
kids the future ummah is ruined so
that's why we need to make sure we're
very careful with our words and when we
afterwards that divorce so easily it's
not that easy you know so yes as we're
careful you know what doing fear except
etcetera table well if yes happy days um
we need to be careful with the word
divorces especially relating to women
because exactly what women doing
going to ask a man for divorce is not
the same as men going to ask a woman for
divorce exactly a woman a man can do
talk to a woman without a consultation
or a woman doing
hola is a completely different kettle
official together and hadith has come
that if a woman asked for divorce for no
reason yeah then she is to be given such
and such a punishment she will not be
you know the fragrance of jannah she
will not smell then so on yeah it's not
the same
like for example he mentions that the
reason talaqa stimulated the three is
because the pagan arabs used to abuse it
they used to divorce their wives and
their wives wanted to move on and they
would take them back and they would do
this over and over again allah
legislated to free so let's not get the
talaq thing of i'm in power i'm yes
there is that element but also that if
you abuse it allah subhanahu wa is the
the reason allah registers that your
wife would have to go and have intimacy
get married with another man that's the
consequence so it won't be your wife
anymore but we won't be a wife anymore
but the point is this bro if it's your
wife and you bro you don't you don't
want to give that divorce and you gave
it because your stupidity that comes at
a cost so let's not make it seem like
the talaqa thing that we have is
something that we carry and it's yeah
i'll use however like no we can fire him
it can backfire us by the way this is a
deep topic inshallah in the coming uh
times in february when the documentaries
are gonna begin to have internet dove
into this i mean
until next time happy birthday across
your hands
you